so what other plans you have now they're
here in Japan anything you want to do or
where you feel like we're actually low
on time like yeah you've got tomorrow
and then well tomorrow we actually have
a rehearsal for the event oh that's
gonna be a thing so basically tomorrow
can't do much yeah the day after is the
awards show so yeah I'll be gone then
I'm leaving the next day what's your
enemy of the year if you're presenting
that
um my anime of the year did you wait did
you vote on the anime Awards
they said come presents an award will be
for all your stuff and I was like sure
I'll go let me know what day I gotta
show up and that was that was about it
awesome I don't even know how to vote
um but uh I mean well I I will think
it's it's cool like they didn't make me
do a bunch of shout outs or anything
yeah yeah yeah show up good so very nice
of them what would you have voted as
your anime of the year that's so for
2022 yeah I imagine yeah um I didn't
watch too much anime there uh okay these
boys didn't I'm right there I watched a
fair amount okay let's all go through
and say ours and maybe it'll change but
let's start over over there
you should say yours first because
you're we're going to sway your opinion
yeah I'll go last I'll go Bochy the rock
is not from last year uh technically it
is or maybe spy family is it nominated
for not nominated for some reason you're
like spy families from last year yeah so
that's a really good one that I did
watch that was good I guess I'd go with
that just because goal isn't included
yeah I don't know why only recency
buyers yeah yeah I think you like
because because they have problems with
that a few years ago but we will include
falling our anime of the Year prediction
yeah I just go for spy family because I
uh I watched it the whole way it's just
a nice wholesome show yeah I didn't
finish it
got bored really yeah yeah this is this
is Connor's game all right let's go next
when is when is you're gonna like do
assassinating when is that gonna happen
again like it's like she just became a
housewife and she like actually became a
housewife yeah but that's what people
like right no yeah he's still doing spy
[__] why isn't she being an assassin
still it's [__] up it's called spy
family not assassin family yeah yeah
I feel like they had a really cool
character and they just left it they
were like well [__] it I don't know yeah
I should be a housewife man yeah uh my
anime of the year
chainsaw man but it kind of was there
because that last tier too yeah that was
awesome technically yeah technically
yeah it's like I don't think anything
did blew my mind more I honestly kind of
agree with you like like I hate being
that guy who goes for it yeah yeah but
it it kind of It kind of wants to go
it's pretty [__] amazing it was kind
of [__] amazing like I don't know how
to be like no I think God's Gonna whip
out something crazy now I'm just uh made
in this too okay okay okay I haven't
watched me the best too yeah that was
not nominated uh what yeah not many
people watched me in the middle you
wouldn't have gone the votes yeah I
think it's really good too yeah yeah I I
don't think it would get votes it didn't
get nominated I don't know how uh what I
think is going to win the anime Awards
I'm gonna make this prediction now so if
if it's correct by the time oh here's
what we do say like five anime right now
yeah and you'll look like a genius
they'll edit out the wrong ones all
right so just list them off chainsaw man
yeah I know what's going to win it's
attacking Titans gonna win oh
I just like the memes honestly the memes
are the best parts yeah I've seen the
memes and I have Aaron talking to well I
guess I want to spoiler but you know the
meme with Aaron talking hold on a second
why do you think it's underwhelming I
think Attack on Titan is like right at
its best right now
um with uh you know without without
spoiling uh like the plot twist that
happened in the previous season and uh
some of the hype [__] that happens
that's [__] we we are definitely not
crazy stuff's happening yeah yeah why do
you think it's I think just the way that
they're I think it's the way they're
releasing it has been really killing
yeah fatigue right I'm dude like I
thought I was so ready for this to be
the final season when I kind of figured
out it wasn't gonna be I was like my
final season final edition part three
as we've discussed before with like you
know Netflix jail and stuff like that
like how a show releases is really
impactful in terms of my own enjoyment
absolutely and I find that the way
they've been releasing Attack on Titan
and you know not I don't know whose
fault it is or where the blame should be
put but I think it's been killing the
hype for me they're milking it they're
milking it
I don't even know if they're milky I
don't know if it's a mess of because
they change Studio as well which means
like what was that about so I don't
think they're milking it maybe maybe in
terms yeah maybe in terms of like the
release schedule because it takes a long
[__] time to make Attack on Titans as
good as it is I think it does yes and I
think I would prefer them to just have a
more extended break rather than split up
to five million different parts yeah
that's been killing my enjoyment because
it's like it's like the where did they
release the uh the code GEOS they
released a key to the Exile but it was
like this is Way Way Back by the way
like and this was like where I [__]
loved Code Geass and they just kind of
release these parts four Partridge all
over the place it was like they dropped
one they were like it's coming next year
nothing and they just dropped two parts
in one day yeah didn't say anything it's
like what the [__] like Can it can we
get some kind of consistency going on
here like it's like having like the
accurate amount of like enjoyment or
expectation knowing what to come in with
it and what to expect helps so much with
yeah kind of figuring it out like they
should like give you a date yeah or just
tell me when it's actually gonna end
stop calling it The Final Season stop
telling me this [__] and it's [__]
with my expectations they mean this [__]
like [__] Photoshop files is like you
know like I I think I think final edit
yeah this is this is the real thing the
actual final Edition version 20. I I
feel like to actually enjoy Attack on
Titan I need to wait till it's done and
go back and re-watch all of it again in
like one sitting almost like one kind of
just to get a real good enjoyment this
is why I don't watch anime weekly
because I feel like some in cases like
this you just you enjoy them it just
drops yeah I'm kind of like a marathon
kind of guy oh I want it all in one go
and it just it I and I agree but also I
really love the public discourse that
goes on every week oh shame I love like
you know last of us I love watching
people get angry every week at dumb
stuff that doesn't matter try watching
One Piece weekly
um
nothing happened again yeah most weeks
nothing happens but every once in a
while one episode is really really good
yeah
that's when you like times nothing
happens being in the end on that feels
so great like being able to have a
shared experience with thousands of
other people yeah without knowing
anything about each other it's kind of
cool what I do is I just open up Twitter
and if I see one piece trending I'm like
oh wow
wow they actually did the same thing
where you know uh where something big
happened in the last Arc of one piece
and I was like all right it's time to
catch up to one piece I guess yeah yeah
um like I don't know there are a lot of
content creators who can do like weekly
one-piece content or weekly like Naruto
content when that was still airing and
I'm like how the [__] do you have enough
to talk there are some content creators
who are still here
I see a lot of uh uh no I think it was
Sasuke fighting dinosaurs uh from
Jurassic Park
yeah yeah did you guys I've heard of
this
I thought it was an edit when I saw it
I'm like this this cannot be legit
and I'm just thinking back to all like
the boruto fans that are like yeah it
gets good later on yeah and then we get
that so the crazy thing is I saw one
week right yeah and I swear this all
right I didn't watch it but I swear the
ark must have gone on for like a month
at least because at first it was one
like Raptor and I was like haha that's
funny it's probably a one-off episode
nothing can happen next week I see more
clips
um Sakura gets attacked by a
brontosaurus and then there's
pterodactyls flying in lightning and I'm
like what is happening now this has gone
crazy and there's there's even once and
where he's like Genji genjutsu doesn't
work on this Raptor and I'm like what on
Earth is happening
I was so confused but I don't know it
could have been an edit I I don't know
no no I'm pretty sure that's just boruto
every time in my life yeah every time I
like watch a clip of borrow so I just
like what what have you done to my boy
what have you done to my boy I just
imagine like Musashi Kishimoto just like
a single tear like goes down
he's like it wasn't worth your money
actually I gave him the right so he
wipes the deal with like a stack of
bills I'm so sad it's like add more
Raptors
so wait why are they fighting Raptors I
don't know because boruto oh okay okay
sorry I shouldn't ask that was the
definition
crazy that it happens I yeah I mean I
think I I I think Naruto should have
just ended if I'm being honest
um well like on a hot day I mean I mean
I feel like if you're gonna make a new
series with Naruto with a big franchise
like Naruto just wait a few years you
know wait wait for the death of the
franchise to kick in before you suddenly
just reboot it into something but I I
feel for for someone like hishimoto and
a series like Naruto it would be almost
impossible to like move on from that
because you know remember he tried he
tried to release Samurai 8 which is that
like other manga that he started I don't
remember that's exactly no one read it
because no one read it and it got
canceled after like three volumes
because it's like no one read it
everyone was like we just want more
Naruto and it's like I feel for like an
artist like that it's so hard to like
move on from something else unless the
thing you move on from is like even
better than what you were original yeah
yeah and like the only example of like
an artist who's successfully done that
it would probably be like you know going
from you you Hakusho to Hunter
oh well those are the same dudes it's
the same guy wow yeah they did great
yeah yeah same guys like you actually
was already amazing and then he was like
okay I'm gonna try and one-up it and he
did you know so Joey still needs to
watch Hunter yeah I'm saying this is
someone who's never seen hunt Hunter oh
okay it was good yeah one of my
favorites yeah exactly yeah and it's
like it's just yeah and I feel that's
the only way that like Kishimoto would
be able to like
start a new series and actually like
move on from Naruto but no more ninjas
or I don't know but then he was like
I'll just do a a spin-off of his son
yeah nobody wants that no I I think who
wants the sun yeah I think it's actually
a different mangaka so he's only uh he's
like overseeing he's overseeing yeah but
I mean what does overseeing which means
he's retired with stacks of cash yeah
which means he's on the payroll chilling
out with uh mimosas having a good time
he basically learned from Toriyama and
he's like oh you made how much off GT
yeah it's like also the same thing yeah
yeah he gets in a zoom meeting and it's
just like oh yeah we're thinking about
adding dinosaurs to Naruto uh is that
cool for you he's like yes keep going
yeah he's like I don't see why not
Jurassic Park did well yeah exactly
exactly yeah Hunter Hunter though they
finally announced that it's it's not
going on Hiatus anymore it's just
straight up cancer it's just straight up
Council yeah I was hoping for something
else yeah yeah yeah which why
because right now it feels like just
commit to the Hiatus because we've
that's what they've been doing for like
20 years I'm glad that they just
committed to the fact that we're never
gonna see the end of the story because
we we never were even with the Hiatus
but he he's coming back last year like
four times I saw that now my hopes were
high he had like two million likes on a
tweet of him just being like I might
come back he drew a tree and I got two
million yeah yeah I was like what the
[__]
yeah I think I think it's because
they've finally realized they're just
like it it like tagashi was just halfing
copium when it came to like coming back
he's just like yeah I'm definitely
coming maybe yeah I could do that yeah
it's such a good [__] show and he
took a nap and woke up nah never mind
yeah he took a nap woke up when he was
six years later he was like oh [__] okay
he's like all right I can't do it
anymore guys yeah yeah but I'm glad I'm
glad it's at least like I'm glad it's
not gone Hiatus because I can like put
in my mind okay this is finished now I
can put it away but it doesn't have an
ending right it's just stopped yeah well
that's so [__] yeah I mean bazook fans
like first time
continuing berserk uh yeah but it's not
the same yeah it's
it's a different you know it's a
different author so there's always no
matter what even if it like [__]
slaps there's always going to be that
group of people who are like well is
this the berserk that was going to
happen though you know yeah you know did
you read berserk at all no no sorry it
was good actually well I was telling one
of the girls being a dark fantasy I
think the best Dark Fantasy is berserk
like which one would you recommend
someone start with if I've never watched
anything like in that type of shoes
oh yeah berserk is definitely because
like berserk is inspired uh some more of
a I've watched anime but I don't read
manga like ever okay if don't watch
don't watch the Berserk anime
um except the 90s one 90s yeah I like
the 90s the nice one's decent I feel
like if you are ever interested in manga
if you start off with berserk that's
where like the peak of manga is yeah if
you ever were interested in Reading you
like Elton ring right yeah Elden ring is
like that all that kind of imagery and
the the scale of the monsters and all
that it's all very berserking the
creator of the Soul Series has that his
biggest influence was berserk it's it's
I mean I have seen the guy with the big
sword which does remind me yeah which is
yeah which is the yeah the style looks
like it yeah
um yeah it was one of my favorites I
think they actually have his sword in
the game or a sword that looks bigger
yeah
for ages you can dual wield them as well
oh [__] yeah
you don't get too much benefit from dual
wielding the big you don't get that much
in fact it's actually worse I'm pretty
sure but it looks cool
it's a statement at that point you know
what would you say then is like your
like all-time favorite anime that you've
seen like if you had to pick one oh man
that's I know that's a hard question
difficult
um and I'm I'm sort of the dude so I
will say my choice wouldn't be based on
what I objectively think is the best
anime I don't know the answer for that
either yeah it would pretty much just be
the one I grew up with right it has the
best memories right yeah so it'd
probably be like Naruto or one piece
because those are the first ones I watch
okay so it's kind of like I don't know
if they're the best objective anime ever
but which fan base you will ask yeah oh
yeah I mean I I still think you know I
still think they're both great shows but
one piece especially is that's still
going strong in fact one piece is going
stronger than ever after what 20 years
yeah 30 now yeah wanna was [__]
insane um
so long yeah I'm right there with you
man so long yeah even Joey needs to
catch yeah but yeah it's my one piece
video is just going to be a business
class flight review at this point
because I am only reading it on flights
oh really that's actually what a lot of
people yeah because I've got a lot of
stuff so just stick a GoPro and I just
[__] read it and then I'm like all
right cool this video is going to take
like 12 years and it's just all gonna be
flights yeah yeah I don't know what I
don't know why you are doing it all in
one video you could easily like split
that up into seven I just want to make
like just one giant video because like
one piece fans are like kind of like
Jojo fans and that's yeah they like they
want anything like as soon as you finish
an arc they're like what did you think
of that Arc tell me tell me everything
what is it rank I need to know yeah I
know I just want to go through it then
I'll make a bunch of One Piece content
after yes but I want to make one giant
one piece video I'm like that is it go
just go to that video If you ever wanted
me to work yeah I thought about doing
that for the JoJo video as well I was
like yeah it's just easy if I just do it
all in one big video yeah I think so too
yeah well look look forward to Connor's
video you in about 10 years
I think it'll come out
either
late this year or early next year okay
it's gonna take forever because I'm you
heard it here again
for like seven months okay let's get an
update where are you where are you at
right now I'm not halfway nearly halfway
halfway you're nearly halfway uh Arc
which are Thriller bars okay okay okay
that one wasn't my favorite art person
it was all right it was it was all right
it was all right it wasn't my favorite
because I don't want to say too much I
don't want to hear anything I'm trying
my best not to talk about it yeah
but uh I mean I'm enjoying it I'll just
say that much okay that's good I'll see
you for the video yeah we'll say before
open up this video like Jesus Christ the
second coming of Christ himself another
year another year if hyping it up and
nothing I'm saying I'm not going to talk
about it and then it's gonna come out
yeah this year well maybe next year
we'll see yeah he's backpeddling just
don't like Sydney read that [__] yeah
yeah sorry guys we're delaying the video
one week yeah